well I think faith is inherently good
because one it teaches you humility
there is something bigger than you and
secondly it leads to certain principles
that that are not tradable that are not
not not you know not relative and I
think those two things are good aspects
of faith however i think if faith is a
badge of identity it can lead to
identified entity in opposition to other
people and to fanaticism in the pursuit
of that so I think that's the flipside
of faith standing for certain absolute
values is that it is that people of
faith can believe sometimes that that
their faith gives them the right to do
things that most people would regard as
wrong or a parent but but I think a
world without faith would be a greatly
diminished world and I think the most
difficult thing in in today's society is
to answer what is I think a deep
spiritual yearning within people but a
great confusion about the practices the
organization the structure the theology
of organized religion I think that poses
great problems for people so there you
go